All right. So, let's go into this
objection. John 13:16. This came up in
that video that I posted. And that video
was done ages
ago. Okay. Ages ago,
right? Praise Jesus that he helped me
lose the weight. And in Jesus name, may
he help me keep the weight out
permanently until the Lord comes or
until he summons me into his presence.
May I never become obese again in Jesus
name. Lord, give me this victory for
your glory and not use it for vanity.
John
13:16. Here you go. John
13:16. Most assuredly I say to you, a
servant is not greater than his master,
nor is he who is sent greater than he
who sent him. So this was posted by some
coward who wouldn't call me on Skype and
try to debate me on this passage. So
notice again how they abuse and torture
and butcher God's word to their shame
and humiliation because God raises up
his true servants. And I pray I'm one of
them filled with the spirit to shame
their blasphemies and lies and assault
against their God and judge Jesus Christ
our Lord. Okay.
Now, John
13:16, most assuredly I say to you, a
servant is not greater than his master,
nor is he who is sent greater than he
who sent him. See, Jesus ain't equal to
the father because the father sent him
and he was the father's servant on
earth. That again just shows you how
blind, how demonic, how wicked these
tools of the devil are. Reread that
passage with me. Read it one more
time. Notice what Jesus actually says. A
servant is not greater than his master.
Who says that Jesus is greater than the
father? Nor is he who is sent greater
than the one who sent him? Who said that
Jesus the one sent is greater than the
father who sent him? Who in the world
thinks that Jesus is greater than the
father who sent him? and greater than
the
father for whose sake he became a
servant. Does anyone believe
that? Does anyone think that Jesus is
greater than his father who sent him?
Greater than his father on whose behalf
he became a
servant. Must Jesus be greater than the
father to be God? Well, if he's greater
than the father, then you'd have to
question the deity of the father, right?
See how stupid this
is? Second problem with this. Jesus is
using human
relationships to describe his
relationship to the father as well as
the relationship of disciples to him. So
whoever quotes this passage to deny the
trinity only shows that he or she is a
pervert because according to them they
just argue that human slaves are
inferior in value to their human masters
because Jesus is using human
relationships as an analogy. So, are
they telling you that a human slave is
inferior in value and dignity and worth
than their human masters? Or that when a
parent sends a child on an errand, the
child is inferior in dignity and value
to the parent? Is that what they're
telling
you? You see how wicked and demonic this
argument is?
A servant will be less than a master in
position and status, not in essence or
value or
worth. Someone sent will be
less in position and
status, not equal in authority to the
one who sent him. But it doesn't make
the one sent inferior in essence and
value and dignity to the one that sent
him or
her. This is a special kind of stupid.
Right? Everyone got it? But let me show
you another saying of our
Lord that these heretics don't quote.
And you'll see why. Yes, a servant is
not greater than his master. No one says
Jesus is greater than the father. Yes,
the one sent is not greater than the one
who sends him. No one said Jesus is
greater than the
father. But can someone sent be equal to
the one that sent him in value and
dignity in essence?
Absolutely. Can his servant be equal in
essence and nature and value and dignity
to the one whom he serves? Absolutely.
Because now let's read Matthew 10 24-2.
Same Jesus. Matthew
10:24-25. Same Jesus. Watch here. Same
Lord. Same
Bible. Watch here. Joel, if you're here,
I'm going to call you next to answer the
questions asked of you by the
Muhammadan. A disciple is not above his
teacher. Exactly. Nor a servant above
his master. Exactly. But now though a
disciple and servant is not above his
master teacher, he can be equal to his
master and teacher. Because now notice
Matthew
10:25. Read guys, same lord. It is
enough for a disciple to be like his
teacher. The word is hos as his teacher
and a servant like his master. A servant
as his master. If they call if they've
called the master of the house Belzebug,
how much more will they call those of
his household? Surprise, surprise. So
though a disciple can't be better or
greater than his teacher and a servant
can't be better or greater than his
master, a disciple, a servant can be
as his teacher and master just like him
in your
face. Wow.
Wow, who would have thought it? So you
see what our Lord said? The same Lord
who said a servant is not greater than
his master and no one thinks Jesus is
greater than the father or the one sent
greater than the one who sends him. That
same Jesus says, "Yet the servant can be
as his master like his master. And a
disciple or the one sent can be as his
teacher as the one who sends him like
the one who sends him like his
teacher." Why did they quote that for
you
guys? Why don't they quote Matthew
10:24-2?
So yes, a servant is not equal to his
master in position, in rank, in
authority, but a servant is equal to his
master in essence, in dignity, in value.
We're talking about human
relationships. So there you go.